ده يومين ستستضيف المانيا دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي لعقد اجتماعي رانشتاين المنتظري
لتجديد التعهدات ومناقشه المزيد فيما
يتعلق بالدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا بالحديث
عن اسطول الدبابات الذي تطلبه اوكرانيا
لانتقاله تركيز الحربي من السماء الى
اليابسه تحاول بولندا ان تلبي النداء
باربع 10 دبب من طراز اثنين الالمانيه
الالمانيه الصنع هذا النوع من الدبابات
موجود لدى جيوش ثلاثه عشره دوله من دول
الناتو بمجموع يزيد عن
2300 دبابه وفقا المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه من بينها فنلندا وكندا
كلاهما مستعدتان بالمناسبه لكن تقديمه
مالي اوكرانيا يحتاج اذنا من الحكومه
الالمانيه التي لم تتحرك تجاه ذلك بعد
واكتفت بالقول انها يجب ان لا تورد الا
اذا اتفق حلفائك الرئيسيون وخاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على هذا الامر حسب
الخبراء فان الجنود الاوكرانيين اذا حصلوا
على ليوبارد اثنين سيحتاجون على الاقل سته
اسابيع ليجيد استخدامها بفعاليه ما بين
المدفعيه وتمهيد الطرق وحمايه الجروح
وبينما تحاول كل دوله ان تجود بالموجود
لديها فان روسيا تجهزوا ردها دائما وعلى
لسان المتحدثه باسم خارجيه موسكو ماريا
خروفه التي وصفت بريطانيا بالدوله التي
تدعم النازيين الجدد وعليه اقرت فرض
عقوبات على ست وثلاثين شخصيا في لندن من
بينهم وزير الخارجيه جينز كلافلي ورئيس
اركان الجيش سانتوس اما دي مسيوبي المتحدث
باسم الكرملين كما ذكرنا بالامس علق انه
مهما قدم الغرب من دبابات سيتم حرقهها
[موسيقى]
وبولندا والدول الاوروبيه الاخرى التي
تتحدث عن خطتها لمرحله جديده من الامداد
بمعدله عسكريه اكثر تقدما لاوكرانيا من
تغيير الوضع على ارضه يجب ان يدركوا ذلك
انهم يطيلون هذه القصه فقط ويزيدون من
متاعب الدوله الاوكرانيه لن يغير ذلك اي
شيء ستستمر العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وستحترق تلك الدبابات مثل غيرها وسيتم
تحقيق اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه